just my final demo of e3 oh man a sad
but it's gonna be it's gonna be a great
last one I was looking into this game
just the last few days and I'm really
excited about it we have the guys for
adventures of PIP on the stage we got
Kathy mark and Sharif guys it's a
pleasure to have you on your doing how
are you doing have you survived III yeah
barely oh my yola you'll look like
really happy but also kind of tired
richer we're like tired how I feel half
so ever do what are you gonna show off
today well how are you gonna tell us
about the game so you know um just so
everybody knows adventure as a pip was a
kickstart project that we did last month
we didn't get funded but we haven't
given up we're really working hard on
the project still we're going to reboot
this kickstarter in july end of july and
try to get this game funded we wanted to
show you a quick video that we put
together first for the kickstarter that
kind of tells you a little bit about the
game the game is very unique I mean it's
a very original idea very innovative
mark came up with it and I love this
idea so so this is the idea that you
start as a single pixel is that right
give us the backstory cuz its oh it is
up but there's a trailer give us the
backstory picture X where we could talk
over to can we talk / determined yeah
what yeah we could talk of the chairs
out here it comes so what you see in a
storyline is that an evil queen comes
she takes all the pixels from the
kingdom and everybody gets derezzed and
you as a single little pixel have to
save the entire kingdom from this evil
queen and so as you kill enemies you
absorb the pixels into yourself and you
gain new abilities and so what we're
going to demo what Kathy's going to demo
is all the different abilities that
you're going to have and all the
evolutions and what they do for you okay
Susie's on the video there's multiple
stages of pips evolution yeah and we're
going to be able to see like some of
those stages we unlocked all the
evolution stages for up to a point for
the sake of this demo but you won't have
them all in the beginning so with no
further ado yeah there's our demo let's
cut to the demo so we start off with the
world map you select the stage that
you're going to go into right now just
there are forests seen this is where the
whole game play starts out and what you
can see is that our environments are
really low resolution and eventually as
you got further into the game the
resolutions get higher and higher that's
because and everything is uprising
everything's getting more difficult the
more pixels an enemy has the the denser
it is the more abilities it has so it
gets more you know to get more
challenging in that sort of way as you
see here as Kathy's playing pip only has
one ability right now and that's really
the ability to hop over things and this
is shortly after the village has been
derezzed and pip is now escaping trying
to get to the the Evil Queen to rescue
the princess so right now a lot of the
game plays is very typical hop and Bop
type of gameplay because i reminisced of
like thomas was a little bow did you
think it'll shape for their yeah so we
play with a lot of just moving platforms
and jumping enemies and you can hop on
your enemies to defeat them at this yeah
so what was in that chest there I missed
a Vista what was inside it oh it's coin
so there's gonna be a monetary system
where you can then go in between levels
and then purchase new upgrades
purchasing your weapons so don't be a
lot of things that you can find it also
be a lot of hidden items that you can
search for in like little hidden zones
in secret areas oh just start borrow
this is hard Oh Kathy go he's got scales
yes she does he does that give a less
kid icarus tattoos on her wrist how'd
you get such a Casilla a lot of practice
oh it's not over yet okay super gamers
gamer spark where did you get this idea
from that if this was your idea yo I
grew up on pixel games I'm a kid of the
80s yeah yeah I've been working in the
industry for a while and I started out
in the GBA GBA games I'm an animator too
so I I didn't like to look what so so me
and Mark used to work at way forward I
got him when he was out of CalArts
working out way forward as a QA guy and
then what we were doing is like Game Boy
Color to Game Boy Advance and the art
was a lot more limited back then and
then mark stay that way forward for
almost what ten years for ten years Wow
and art evolved over time like
ridiculous you know so I think what he
told me when we were first looking at
this to do internally in the studio he
said you know I want to do something
that kind of is like a homage to like
all the different styles of art that I
had worked on in seen in games but at
the same time I wanted to have a real
story behind it so when you so how did
you I can have missed that how exactly
did you a lot and this new form right so
you've got fewer pixels where did you
get this from oh no what I'm sorry how
um how you kind of getting these new
forms is because they're unlocked
already so as you what we're doing is
we're skipping through right being able
to earn the new abilities you know just
for the demo purposes once she got
through the midpoint she was able to get
three new evolutions and the way you get
to access more abilities as each enemy
you kill the pixels come out of it and
go into yourself oh so what you have
enough you could day an upgrade yeah but
what you have kind of evolved more you
can like dville right you can use to
devolve for specific situations so as
you can see when kathy has to go into
like a tight area she'll be evolve or if
she's too heavy for certain blocks
you'll fall through those blocks so she
got to make sure that she stays small
for them but with each evolution [ __ ]
the whole idea and moral behind the game
is that as you evolve yes you become
stronger but there's also advantage of
stooping small as well so the idea is
that you know their strengths no matter
what size or shape you are that that's
always got nice m yeah a nice message
about video games and generally you know
sometimes you don't need fake fancy
graphics sometimes won't pixels enough
that I symbol is about as carpentry of
that yeah absolutely you also see some
villagers scattered throughout the
environment they're also going to be
rescued as you go through the world they
also escape through the dark Queens that
attack on the town the city so you'll
have to go through and save them all
from the world right now there it's a
little bit of a like a feature
enhancement that Marcus adding into the
levels to pick up isn't exactly and they
way and the villagers will depending on
where they're placed there some could be
placed in really hard to access areas
and you'll hold you know bigger
unlockable things like secret weapons
and stuff like that each other so here
Catholic and evolve to access these
small areas or she can revolve and then
break through the blocks down there
so do you have any other stages you can
show up for us today or is this oh wait
did you like skip ahead to another one
just to kind of show up so the diversity
in the game some layer level stuff you
know for the we have like any teleport
for right now or no up like swamp levels
or any of the dark caverns or what our
plan is for we're trying to put together
a demo that we can probably show at PAX
can we talk about that yeah yeah yeah a
little bit sure um and what we're going
to do is try and put together a level
package of the forest we're also going
to have a swamp level and and a caves
level as well so what was your plan date
over the next step few weeks or months
for for like getting Pipo they're like
when you planning on having it in a
forum where people can buy it like oh
yeah so um we're targeting January right
now because we're looking at everything
that was saying you know without you
know for sure the Kickstarter being
funded we need to like start
communicating that later date you know
because we don't know how many people
we're gonna always be working on pip
even if we have to donate blood to keep
it going but you know the Kickstarter
gets funded hoping we could get it done
in like November you know but the
biggest thing for us is making sure it's
done right you know get that critical
mass of content get get it so that all
the game plays super polished and that
just it feels amazing for the players so
that that's really the goal for us is
saying let's make it perfect but January
is kind of a recent late date okay so
any people want to know more about my
paper how can they do it where should
they go I'm sorry people to know more
about the game where where shall we go
go to WWE games com or go and hit us up
on Twitter at tic toc games facebook
will definitely get stuck on putting up
updates on our Twitter and we've got a
Tuesday twitch feed that we do every
week yeah everything people can people
can get to your Kickstarter through
their think so that right absolutely
they could go to the link now but
because we haven't rebooted it yet they
will just see like all the information
that was on there before anybody who
funded it you're getting the updates now
you know about this today so thanks
joining us but yeah so you'll you could
check that link and and that will be
active again in july end of july really
well guys just being a really lovely
having you on stage speak to your man
your game and it could change it so
really no right over there like what I
likes crazy whose bones you ever think
you'd be on the stage across we can t my
gosh okay I got a picture I think I
would either he's totally cool took a
picture with Cathy that was awesome
that's awesome look guys mean I just say
I should pleasure good luckily my rocket
man really appreciate you guys